car rempli mon thé ou le soir agressif
sécurité non assurée aux heures de
pointe voici ce que distendurait les
usagers de la ligne 16 qui relie 50 ans
en Yvelines à Cergy-Pontoise un
collectif d'usagers à lancer une
pétition pour alerter le transporteur il
a déjà recueilli plus de 100 signatures
en l'espace d'une semaine
quand on a eu
l'idée entre nous plusieurs personnes
nous ont soutenu pour la faire et
lorsqu'on l'a fait et qu'on commence à
passer à discuter aux gens de ce qu'ils
en pensent tout de suite on a quasiment
les gens qui veulent signer participer à
cette revendication commune on est
beaucoup d'usagers donc pas assez de
place assise donc bien souvent les
usagers sont obligés de descendre après
c'est la vétusté des cars des fuites des
sièges cassés des clims qui ne
fonctionnent plus
en cas de panne pour l'avoir vécu on a
l'impression qu'il y a pas de suivi
notamment on a crevé récemment enfin le
car à crevé récemment et ben on a
continué le trajet avec la roue crevée
de son côté Veolia le transporteur
reconnaît les difficultés et souhaite
dresser un état des lieux
tout le monde sont prises très très au
sérieux puisque ça fait partie
des deux jouets le collectif attend
encore plus de signatures avant de
remettre la pétition au transporteur à
la fin du mois